good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday and since the Israeli army
invaded the Gaza Strip last night I
suppose I have to talk about it even
though it makes me miserable to counter
that misery I'm going to show you
footage of bubbles the nerdfighting
puppy being cute while I talk the reason
I hate talking about Israel and
Palestine is that people get so
emotional that the quality of discourse
is awful
mostly it's just people screaming the
Palestinians are animals or the Israelis
are animals both of which are true of
course the Romans pointed it out long
ago hank homo homini lupus man is a wolf
to man so ok when people talk about this
they often say that the anger goes back
thousands of years that's true of course
but the roots of every war go back
thousands of years and just because it
arguments old doesn't mean it's
intractable for instance Hank our
argument over whether the chuck-e-cheese
bands version of you say it's your
birthday is or is not great you promy
con dates back more than 20 years and
yet despite the relative ancientness of
this argument I don't want to kill you
over it so let's not start 2000 years
ago let's start in 1947 when Britain
still had about a fifth of the World
colonized the UN decides that Bryn's
colonization of Palestine should end in
the two independent states should be
created Israel a sovereign homeland for
the Jewish people and an independent
Palestine the disputed holy city of
Jerusalem which would be surrounded by
Palestine would be run by the UN
excellent idea and in fact everyone and
I mean everyone who is not entirely
crazy still agrees that this is the only
solution an independent Israel an
independent Palestine and a shared
Jerusalem and yet it hasn't happened 60
years in several wars later Israel has
dramatically expanded its borders as a
defense against further attack and
Palestinian land which is still not an
independent country has been split into
two disconnected areas the West Bank at
a 25 mile long area along the
Mediterranean Sea called the Gaza Strip
both Palestine and Israel have unfairly
attacked and dehumanized the other and
it's useless I'll be attempting to make
historical judgments about whose
awfulness has been worse so then in 2006
the Palestinians have their first really
free elections and the FATA party which
has been the most powerful political
party in Pakistan for decades loses the
winner the internationally recognized
terrorist organization Hamas a brief
primer on Hamas they're the Palestinian
arm of the Muslim Brotherhood this
radical group that sucks worse than the
Chuckie Cheese band and has inspired
such a number one organizations as
al-qaeda and
Taliban the Muslim Brotherhood is
illegal in Egypt which is one of the
reasons why the Egyptian government
hates Hamas Hamas is responsible for
tons of rocket attacks and suicide
bombings in Israel that target civilians
but they're also responsible for almost
all of the infrastructure built in the
last 15 years in the Gaza Strip they
build hospitals and schools and
orphanages Israeli analysts think about
90% of the Massa's budget goes into
social welfare programs the other 10% to
weapons and it's important to remember
that Palestinian voters like American
voters don't vote solely on foreign
policy after all most American voters
prioritized the economy over the Iraq
war so too with the Palestinians but
anyway since the election the Hamas lobs
rockets and Israel responds with better
weaponry tit for tat has worsened
consistently culminating in the invasion
last night ultimately Israel wants to
get Hamas out of power which i think is
a great idea but unfortunately most
analysts feel that this war will
strengthen Hamas rather than weaken it
and now Hank here's the John Green path
to peace in Israel and Palestine in one
minute
Israel needs to stop allowing the
expansion of illegal settlements on
Palestinian territory and begin to
dismantle even the old ones Hamas and
the Alaska martyrs brigade need to stop
all attacks on Israelis immediately
Israel needs to free its political
prisoners Fattah needs to quit ruining
its legitimacy with corruption if they
do that Hamas will be out of power
within a year at that point Fattah and
Israel can sit down together and draw a
map similar to the 1949 map with real
and lasting sovereignty for the
Palestinian people even if it means
Israel opening itself up to some kind of
lack of security that's a situation no
one's going to be happy with but
everyone can live with and then you will
acknowledge that you were wrong to like
the Chuckie Cheese band when you were
five Salaam and Shalom and best wishes